how's gone red my name is Priyanka
welcome back to the moon I hope you both
miss this series I sure as I'll missed
it
let's keep rolling and see how this
keeps going right the wedding and we
were looking for like stuff yes I
remember now that episode was suck yep
if you don't think that episode was
killed you know what you know what it's
not a gay thing or anything it's just
nice you can't can't argue anyway it's
good to be back I had an awesome time in
Paris I saw a lot of things did a lot of
things it was fun good time let's let's
try to get this song hey old man how you
there we need one more ball and I really
don't know I guess we got to go more
south probably yeah there we go I got
this you thought I didn't have it you
fill them you are probably just too fine
huh this is the parking and we still
don't know what happened all right a lot
of people said that she had Alzheimer's
but I don't think shadow and Alzheimer
it can't be out forever I'm sure they
didn't mean to come on we're late what
happened wait is that a rabbit I think
this is the start of all those fallen or
paper one and why would you why would
she obsess over some roadkill
not to mention so many years late don't
ask me you are the woman it's true I
don't poison I'll be convinced that I'm
the only one when you do a cordless
bungee jump that was a last ball that
doesn't even look like a bunny ah
we found the memento it's the bunny okay
so why was ships ask so many questions
never any answers in this game and
that's why you just keep on a plane so
much all right let's go let's ride the
dead bunny back in time let's see how we
do this it's this pretty pretty
straightforward I would say there we go
nice dead running so I'll do like a
mouse solve that dead bunny that's just
how we do it you know it's fantastic
wedding when the momentos roach come on
then hey maybe she saw it as a metaphor
for terrible marriage so years later she
began folding the rabbits because she
was reminded how rotten it or you know
something equally pretentious cool story
Neal cool story bro maybe I don't know
maybe she's like some people said oh
don't drive over it dude
what the [ __ ] some people said that she
had some sort of AI spires I don't I
thought that was more like a common with
boys but maybe cuz both the sisters I
don't know about these things I'm pretty
bad poor thing
what's with that road kills
don't you look at me like that
she wasn't even looking at him smells
like a farm and roadkill deactivate the
scent simulator and get away from here
already
I bet this as a ball no it's not a ball
are we keep walking here no are we
really no okay hmm I can't make out how
the hell that's a rabbit I'm sorry it
looks like a headcrab or something or
like a huh where's this pet time-travel
rabbit it's at a horse that blue horse
are we high right now why didn't that
what in the what wha whoa oh it's most
it's a blue horse dog do it I'm lagging
like crazy what's going on my my lion
all right sorry about that
don't do what you know what don't write
do not write it's ours why not I mean
you can't Harmon what are you five years
old okay I will not write it come on
yeah quit wasting time Neal oh crap that
can't be good
ah
Duncan's down the help me damn it this
is not in the job description
okay guys an idiot but that's okay
because he ride toys I guess we go what
the hell are we
I hope we will find out what's up with
the lighthouse and stuff like that maybe
uh there it's a horse oh maybe they met
like this ah what are we in time no they
couldn't told me here Oh No okay they
haven't met here it's just really a good
idea she should be okay she's not new to
this anymore who's talking but she has
never done it by herself before I'll be
fine I'm not a child
ah ah ah River no no maybe no no
ah ah I thought yeah chicken neck what's
the matter
let's get ah hey hey I love the music ha
I wonder if Neal got off that horse yes
yeah way to break the moon Neil or once
they're just 19% more than I can handle
what a [ __ ] is she gonna get up on that
no girl Oh what the corncob what a
corncob what sorry ah oh my god I'm on a
horse gallop so what girl whoa
Wow Wow Wow okay [ __ ] is pretty enjoyed
merely
it's beautiful love it let's follow them
sorry what is what is what am i ah
thanks oh sorry about that you find a
boulder that's cool god damn the music
is beautiful I'm just gonna what
oh I got all the bones now the question
is where we unleash them ah
it's gotta be here yep
and so it what is it though supper the
picture
okay let's launch whatever this is
goddamn without music what is this can I
know what it is
how many for it shouldn't be to death
back home
Omega pure genius strikes again I'm
pretty good at this I don't know what's
up with it but I'm solving these like a
ba doo doo doo ah [ __ ] we don't get the
music anymore
all right we're going back in town with
okay it's just listen
oh no this is where you should get the
diagnose because she wasn't diagnosed
okay
it's just dying Orson can we please know
what it is yes we reached it's
consensual on the result so fine
unfortunately like many cases of
pervasive development disorder this is
rather late diagnosis how'd you know
when she were a mere child [ __ ] I
could have saved you a lot of trouble
like her sister but if her sister knows
it doesn't make sense that they wouldn't
check her I don't know do you do you
have any background this is the one by
Tony Edward he's one of the specialists
on this subject you can borrow it free
of charge now just don't help with it
thanks doc totally [ __ ] up the voices
now are you two a couple unmarried and
without any other current legal
application playin yes I see well I
could give you a referral to a
specialized Council if the away strata
thing unsettling in their relationship
no and and yes sir
no it's fine
nonetheless sir they should also get the
bakery it'll help you understand your
condition I'd rather not why is that
well it's your cow in the meantime
there's a thing called equine therapy
that my hyper ranch just north of there
after that oh so that was therapy for I
can call it that them volume hmm still
really confused not gonna lie
told you sir well you didn't actually
tell anyone
can we please find out what's going on
excuse me could you walk emplaced island
to talk the tikkun really bother it's
not that research severe I'll be okay no
problem it's standard policy if there's
anything at all that makes uncomfortable
just let me know
oh nice jump rope
dang him twice thank you huh I guess
that explains the ones in the house oh
yes
that's Tibet longer they'll be calling
Firestone oh we can jump over here the
clock is the item hmm
woven we need one more momenta ah the
Platypus I don't see it I can't believe
this piece of art rush it is dated all
the way back come on it's cat looks like
someone took a good care of it
she's still pretty bad taste in animals
what
platypuses are awesome what are you
talking about huh alright let's charge
the clock and go back in time that one
actually made sense we're taking
umbrellas and all cancer [ __ ] but what
they miss one shoelaces I missed one uh
I thought this was one maybe here or we
can go in here uh okay here we got
something yeah there we go
and let's go back into address um okay
it looks pretty complicated don't turn I
think I mess this up or maybe not
on the contrary Dana yes Perry strikes
again how the hell do I do that I don't
even know
holy [ __ ] okay oh it's pretty though
this is a cinema I do believe it is why
is it shape so on luck I know I can't
believe he paid to see this crap in the
theater no your idiot
luck we're late what does that mean back
in time
yep wait edit holy overcooked Becker
loading the kids in the theater all
bottom Salwa what a loser you go to the
theater by yourself all the time that's
different
no one's competent enough to watch might
look but that aside how could I do my
last through this rubbish
sometimes it's awesome sometimes is it
just a douche in my opinion maybe this
is where they met
please can't they meet here I want them
to be Maya meet here I want to see how
they met this is rather unsettling those
out I don't know if he's leaving now
while you're going bro and thus this
movie sucks on both physical and
metaphysical levels QED quantum Egypt
and dinosaur come on let's go what all
right okay
we're gonna go in this room but we're
gonna end this episode here god damn
it's cooking up to something good I can
just taste the smell I could smell the
smell anyway my Confederate division joy
bus hops out a lot subscribe if you want
to come Bartel the bro on me and i'll
see you next episode over ever Ave hello
just rolls with it okay at this time we
will take below up as big I mean my
pixel didn't die if we do that there's
something over here and see that it's
underwear [ __ ] really I bet it's hard